Zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin schon mal da. Ich bin schon mal da.
Ich bin schon mal da. Bertie Cox mit Utopia hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz, wo Leute vom Chaos Computer Club zu Gast sind, um heute über Eigenhosting zu sprechen. Das sind zum Beispiel der Erdgeist, der Kai und der Dmitry. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Und wir sprechen heute darüber, wie man es schaffen kann, dass man sich selbst darum kümmert, dass die Dienste, die man sonst normalerweise nur im Internet benutzt, dass man die zu Hause macht. Wir haben schon geklärt, warum man das machen sollte. Bastelspaß ist nicht eine unwesentliche Motivation. Wir haben schon geklärt, dass es zumindest für den Anfang sinnvoller ist, wenn man zu Hause mit einer kleinen Rechenmaschine unter dem eigenen Schreibtisch arbeitet. Und wir haben auch geklärt, wie man die dann überhaupt dazu kriegt, dass die mit dem Internet sprechen kann. All das in der ersten Stunde dieser Sendung, die ihr auch im Nachhinein als Podcast hören könnt auf fritz.de oder chaosradio.ccc.de. So, wir haben also jetzt schon einen Computer, der hängt auch im Internet und da muss jetzt Software drauf. Und wir haben jetzt schon so ein bisschen drüber gehalten und es fiel immer wieder der Name. Also gerade wenn es so um die typischen Cloud-Sachen geht, die man so haben will. Also Dateien synchronisieren, Kalender und Kontakte, dass man da zum Beispiel, Kai hat gesagt, ich würde ihn vielleicht schlagen, wenn ich das sagen würde, ich weiß gar nicht, warum er das getan hat, OwnCloud. Das ist eine so eine Software, die kann man halt relativ simpel, also relativ, ich habe mal versucht, eine Anleitung dafür zu schreiben, die ist glaube ich fünf oder sechs Seiten lang, auf einen Rechner drauf spielen. Aber es geht ohne Vorahnung, ohne Vorwissen, mit ein wenig Ahnung so rum, habe ich schon mal probiert. So, aber jetzt erklärt doch mal, was dieses OwnCloud eigentlich ist, was es kann und was es nicht kann.
Ich wollte dir eigentlich nur nicht vorweggreifen, dem Thema, wie ich schon am Anfang tat. Aber das OwnCloud ist eigentlich eine Lösung, die macht so Dropbox und Google Kalender und Google Kontakte und Foto-Flicker-Sharing, alles zum Selbst-Zuhause-Hosten. Und du hast, glaube ich, schon ein Auto erzählt, du hast das benutzt und das halt wirklich auch so in so einer kurzen Fünf-Schritt-Anleitung so downloaden, auf eine SD-Karte packen, in den Raspberry stecken und schon läuft's. So für die eigene Anwendung und je nachdem wie groß und wie viel man das braucht, kann man das halt auch richtig selbst installieren, auf den Server in Datacenter packen. Und dann ist das natürlich viel größer, hat viel mehr Kraft als ein kleiner Raspberry Pi. Aber das macht halt eigentlich so alles, was man eigentlich braucht, um so von der Cloud ein bisschen wegzukommen.
Also das ist tatsächlich dann die Own Cloud, könnte man sagen, also wie das ja auch sozusagen heißt.
Für mich ist der Begriff Cloud ja immer so negativ besetzt, dass es mir immer schwer fällt, irgendwie um das ins Herz zu legen.
Aber es sagt ja auch Own Cloud, so ist halt die eigene Cloud.
Es ist ja sozusagen, es ist ja dieses, das ist für dich glaube ich nur negativ belegt. Also weil tatsächlich, weil du wahrscheinlich damit verbindest, sozusagen das sind dann auch gleich die großen Anbieter, dabei das Konzept.
Nein, Cloud ist ursprünglich, als die Netzwerkingenieure so Diagramme gezeichnet haben. Das kann dauern, Leute. Da war die Cloud immer genau das unsichere Internetwolke. Genau, die Internetwolke, wo einfach, man weiß nicht, da kommen eventuell, wenn man Glück hat, Daten durch. Aber dem hat man, denen kann man nicht vertrauen. Und man muss dafür sorgen, dass es eventuell noch Alternativen gibt drum rum. Irgendwie passiert da drin irgendwas und dann kommt auf der anderen Seite was an. Die Netzwerkingenieure haben dem immer schon so ziemlich nase rümpfend, sind dem begegnet. Und da jetzt zu sagen, genau da soll meine Daten hin, sollte jedem, dem was an seinen Daten liegt, sollte einfach, nein, die stopft man nicht einfach so in diese Cloud, dieses unsichere Ding, sondern...
Na du weißt halt am Ende nicht, wo die Daten liegen, sondern du siehst nur irgendwie eine Webseite. Und ob das dann bei den Amis oder in deutscher Restriktion, oder ob das öffentlich oder ganz sicher gelagert ist, ob das tausende von Sicherheitslücken hat oder nicht, das weiß man halt einfach nicht.
Apropos tausende Sicherheitslücken, kommen wir zurück zur Umgangsklänge.
Jetzt kommst du mit den Insider-Witzen.
Ja, also einer, verstehe, einer sei mir nochmal geduldet. Nein, wir haben jetzt schon festgestellt, das kann halt so einiges und der Name Cloud bedeutet eigentlich was anderes, aber Sprache lebt, es ändert sich, also es geht darum, dass sie uns sozusagen den Service, den man online nutzen kann, auf dem eigenen Rechner anbietet. Die haben tatsächlich auch in einer letzten Version sogar so eine Art Google Docs-Ersatz da, also gibt es so ein Plugin, was man da benutzen kann. Das ist noch alles sehr wackelig, habe ich das Gefühl, aber es ist auf dem Weg dahin. Trotzdem, oder andersrum, Kai, du benutzt das?
Nee, ich bin ehrlich gesagt ganz schlecht hier, weil ich hier überhaupt zu Hause gar nichts hoste, außer meine Mails und mein IRC und mehr betreibe ich nicht privat. Aber ich betreibe es für andere Leute öfters. Aber ich kenne es halt tatsächlich, die hingehen und die kennen halt den Komfort von dropbox.com oder von Gmail und sagen dann, ja, aber ich will jetzt Rechtsklick machen und das dann meinen Freunden schicken mit den Fotos vom Wochenenden. Und dann sitzt halt immer da, ja, wie machst du das jetzt? Erklärst du ihnen, wie sie irgendwie Gallery und PAP aufsetzen? Oder ach nee, Moment, inzwischen gibt es halt OwnCloud, wo das halt alles echt einfach ist. Du sagst einfach hier Rechtsklick, Share und fertig. Und das ist halt, das ist halt endlich mal eine Eigenlösung, die halt an den Komfort rankommt von damit, wo die Großen mit Geld machen, die halt in der Cloud liegen tatsächlich.
So, trotzdem, wenn man diesen Namen sagt und sich in den Highbrow Nerd-Crisen bewegt, kommt dann auch so ein Augenbrauen hochziehen und Naso rümpfen manchmal. Also das ist so, OwnCloud ist nicht dabei, es hat jetzt der Schluss anscheinend. Das Vorteil ist, man kann es relativ einfach installieren und es kann relativ viel. Was sind die Nachteile?
Sicherheitslücken.
Das ist in PHP geschrieben und...
Erklärt, erklärt. Also, verstehst du, wenn du jetzt sagst, das ist in PHP geschrieben...
Ich hatte schon noch ein und hinterhergeschrieben. Und diese Programmiersprache ist eigentlich eine wandelnde Sicherheitslücke. Diese Programmiersprache wurde nicht entwickelt, sondern sie hat sich von selber entwickelt. Irgendwie jeder, der mal ein Feature brauchte, hat da ein bisschen was herangeklatscht. Und inzwischen ist es so unintuitiv, dass selbst die besten Programmierer, die dort in PHP unterwegs sind, es nicht schaffen, dort wirklich sichere Software zu stricken. Und ist einfach ganz...
Also das beste Beispiel für mich ist immer bei OwnCloud, dass man... Also das ist wirklich... Man muss wirklich dazu sagen, das ist die aller einfachste Lösung, die ich jemals gesehen habe, die so eine Lösung für alles und alles funktioniert. Aber es gibt so Beispiele an Sachen, von Sachen, die in OwnCloud in PHP nachimplementiert sind, wie die komplette WebDAF, sozusagen dieses Protokoll, ist komplett in PHP geschrieben. Obwohl jeder Web Server, also man braucht, man muss das so sagen, OwnCloud ist eigentlich eine Web Anwendung. Also das läuft auf einem Web Server. Und diese Web Server unterstützen alle von sich aus auch WebDAF. Also aber man aus welchem Grund auch immer, wahrscheinlich weil man sich nicht drauf verlassen konnte, was die Web Server in verschiedenen Konfigurationen können und nicht, hat man sich entschieden, bei OwnCloud ein wesentlicher Teil des ganzen Servers in PHP nachzuschreiben. Und laute solche Entscheidungen führen eigentlich zur angreifbaren Code, also der nicht besonders sicher ist.
Ah, da sag ich, würde ich jetzt so als Argument eigentlich bringen, so du kannst das halt bei dir zu Hause laufen lassen, wo keiner hinkommt. Und außerdem, wenn ich mir, also um wieder auf das Beispiel Dropbox zu kommen, ich hab mir da mal einen Account angelegt für ein Projekt auf der Arbeit, wo ich das brauchte. Und inzwischen kriege ich da Spam auf die Mailadresse und ich benutze halt pro Dienst eine eigene Mailadresse und denk mir halt so, hm, woher kommt denn der Spam? Und ist da nur meine Mailadresse abhandengekommen oder sind da auch die Daten abhandengekommen? Und da sag ich mir so, okay, bei OnCloud kann ich immerhin dann selbst den Stecker ziehen, wenn es mir zu heikel wird, während bei den Cloud-Diensten, da regnet es dann halt einfach mal Daten irgendwo raus und du bist halt richtig machtlos.
Na, das ist jetzt mal so eine spannende Frage, die, wenn ich jetzt meinen eigenen kleinen Rechner betreibe und da diese OnCloud irgendwie draufhabe und die hat jetzt mal theoretisch eine Sicherheitslücke angenommen, aber außer mir benutzt diesen Rechner eigentlich gar nicht. Kann die dann trotzdem rausgefunden werden? Also nicht die Sicherheitslücke, sondern kann da jemand meinen Rechner konkret anwenden?
Da gehen doch jeden Tag, wenn man irgendeine IP-Adresse hat, die am Internet sich befindet, da gehen bei mir auf dem Server pro Minute zehn Verbindungsversuche von überall auf der Welt ein, die einfach mal am Türknopf rütteln, um zu gucken, ob es aufgeht. Das ist so wie die kleinen Panker, die über die Straße runterlaufen, an die eben auch mal gucken, ob die Tür aufgeht, und wenn, dann freuen sie sich rein. Und heutzutage das gesamte Internet, alle IP-Adressen aus dem IPv4-Bereich da abzuklappern, geht, wenn du eine fette Leitung hast, die du dir von irgendeinem, ja, als Zombie übernommenen Rechner entwickelst. Ja, oder vom Kongress aus, da bist du in unternem Tag durch alle Rechner durch, und wenn du da nicht hier viel Daten hinschicken musst, weil, wenn dann ganz einfache Anfrage an den Webserver ausreicht, um den Dienst aufzumachen und zu übernehmen, dann, ja, musst du damit rechnen. Wenn du eine Adresse hast, die aus dem Internet erreichbar ist, dann kommt irgendwann auch mal jemand vorbei und rüttelt an deiner Tür. Und dann, schwupps, macht der im besten Fall, benutzt er dich einfach und übernimmt deinen Rechner und macht daraus einen Zombie, um Spam zu verschicken oder...
Das ist also auch nicht ganz ungefährlich, so einen eigenen zu betreiben, oder ist das nur bei OnCloud so?
Das ist eigentlich bei allem, was im Internet so, egal ob selbst geschrieben, ob fertig installiert, ob Open- oder Closed-Source, du hast überall Security-Lücken, ist halt einfach so das Risiko. Und bei den bekannten Anwendungen, die jeder nutzt, gibt es das halt so von der Stange zum Aufmachen. Und wenn es halt selten ist, muss man halt ein bisschen Arbeit rein investieren, aber kriegt die Anwendung trotzdem auf.
Genau, das ist einfach so ein bisschen wie im Straßenverkehr. Du hast da ein allgemeines Lebensrisiko und im Zweifel hast du Backups. Wenn dir jemand den Rechner aufmacht, dann spielst du die Backups wieder ein und dann hoffst du, dass der Anbieter der Software irgendwann mal ein Update einspielt, dass dein Service zu Hause nicht alle Minuten übernommen wird.
Und wenn es ganz wichtig ist, dann gehst du einfach nicht in den Straßenverkehr bzw. stellst die Dokumente einfach nicht ins Internet, sondern lagerst sie auf einer Platte zu Hause. Das ist halt so, muss man halt abwägen, was dann halt wirklich, ja...
Wenn die NSA hinter dir her ist, dann würdest du dir auch in den Arsch treten. Wenn du deine Software nicht pflegst, die du installiert hast auf deinem eigenen Server, der über das Internet zu erreichen ist, dann musst du auch damit rechnen, dass jemand alte und bekannte Sicherheitslücken ausnutzt und wie wir eben in den Nerd-Nachrichten gelernt haben, ist auch eine Firma wie AVM, die die Fritz-Boxen herstellt oder Cisco, nicht davor gefeiert, in den Routern, die ja per Definition dort in großem Stil am Internet angeschlossen sind und in 100.000-fach sogar, dass die, naja, nicht Hintertüchen, sondern Sicherheitslücken aufweisen, mit denen dann der Rechner übernommen werden kann.
Ist Augenteuer jetzt sozusagen die einzige Software, die sowas macht oder gibt es da auch noch Alternativen, also im Sinne von, die muss ich mir nicht sehr zusammen kompensieren, programmieren, was auch immer?
Es gibt diverse Alternativen. Es gibt ein arcos.io, auch ein Projekt, was wie sehr slick aussieht und sich dann nochmal auf den Anfangsanwender richtet. Die machen dann nochmal den genanen Extra Schritt mehr, dass es gebügelt und schick aussieht. Und ich werde da bestimmt jetzt einigen Projekten nicht gerecht, die ich jetzt auch kennen sollte.
Aber zum Beispiel ein sehr beliebter, der vielleicht noch erwähnenswert ist, weil er eben im Gegensatz zu OwnCloud doch sehr viel weniger Code ist und weniger massiv ist. Das ist Devica oder ich glaube, das heißt, ich vergesse immer, doch Devica ist der aktuelle Name. Die hatten irgendeinen anderen Namen davor, aber das kann ich empfehlen. Das Problem ist eigentlich, wenn man sich mit dieser ganzen Thematik beschäftigt, was man sehr oft sieht, ist zum Beispiel, es kommt ein iOS 8 raus, also meistens ist das eine große Version und plötzlich funktioniert nichts mehr. Und wenn man auf diese Daten, wenn man sie braucht, dann kann es durchaus sein, dass man erst mal einen Monat warten muss, bis der nächste Update kommt, bis es wieder funktioniert. Und bei OwnCloud, muss man dazu sagen, sie bemühen sich sehr, um möglichst mit allen populären Geräten kompetibel zu sein. Und beispielsweise bei DeviCal kenne ich das auch von den Medienlisten dort. Der Entwickler da schreibt sehr oft, na, es funktioniert nicht mit Apple, aber das ist nicht mein Problem, denn Apple hat sich nicht an den Standard gehalten.
Genau das andere Ende ist ein Projekt, das heißt ReadyCale, und das ist ein klitzekleines, in Python geschriebenes Skript, was als Mission Statement geschrieben hat, wir sind faul, wir sind stinkend faul. Wir wissen, dieser Standard ist mehrere hundert Seiten lang. Wir haben da keine Lust, den komplett durchzuimplementieren. Wir haben einfach mal alles implementiert, was man braucht, um mit einem iOS, mit einem MacOS, mit dem Android-Telefon und mit dem Windows sprechen zu können und hier ist das Skript, und du kannst es benutzen und das einfach aufzusetzen. Und das macht dir Kontakte und Kalender sinken. Und das tut es sehr schnell, klein und gut. Und es ist dann so das andere Ende des Spektrums, wo die sich dann nicht hinsetzen und sagen, ja, ist nicht unsere Schuld, sondern die gucken, welche Features gebraucht werden und implementieren genau die.
Es gibt also genug Auswahl und es gibt eigentlich nichts mehr, was euch abhalten sollte, das auszuprobieren. Also insbesondere, solange wir nur von Synchronisationsdiensten reden, also die eure Kalender, eure Kontakte oder eure Dateiordner replizieren, also von eurem Rechner auf diesen online Rechner noch übertragen, ist das Backup ja quasi automatisch mitgemacht, weil alle Daten sich ja zu jedem beliebigen Zeitpunkt immer auf mehreren Rechnern befinden. Also auf allen euren Rechnern und dieser kleinen Box, die irgendwo zu Hause stehen hat.
Naja, das ist ja kein Backup, weil wenn du es dann auf deinem Laptop löscht, ist es auch gleich zu Hause gelöscht.
Also wenn du nicht noch regelmäßig Snapshots dann auf deinem Server nimmst, dann wird auch ein gelöschter Kontakt auch synchronisiert. Alles mach mal weg.
Okay, dann müssen wir nochmal unterscheiden. Zwei Arten von Backups. Das eine Backup dient ja dazu zu sagen, der eigene kleine Rechner zu Hause oder irgendwas schmiert irgendwo ab, also so raucht komplett ab. Dann hat man es natürlich die Daten auf einer anderen Maschine. Dieses, ich habe etwas gelöscht und will es eigentlich nochmal wieder haben. Das ist natürlich richtig. Gibt es denn da einfache Lösungen, um sozusagen dem eigenen kleinen Rechner beizubringen, hier nochmal alle Daten irgendwie?
Es geht auf das Betriebssystem an. Mein Lieblingsbetriebssystem FreeBSD bietet mit dem jetzt da mal mitgelieferten Filesystem namens ZFS so ziemlich billig an, keine Ahnung, im Halbstundentakt zu Snapshotten. Und also spricht den aktuellen Stand des gesamten Betriebssystems mit all den Daten einfach jetzt mal zu freezen und zu jedem beliebigen späteren Zeitpunkt wieder zu sagen, roll mal kurz zurück. Und man kann diese Snapshots dann auch überall noch zum anderen Backup-Server hinschicken. Bin ich halt in meiner Administratoren-Säle da irgendwie auch verliebt in dieses Feature und benutze es überall, wo es nur geht. Aber ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich gibt es in Linux eine ähnliche Option.
Auf Linux macht es dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie Googles nach Ubuntu und Backup und findet 20 Lösungen mit verschiedensten GUI, nicht GUI und Abarten. Also da gibt es halt das Spektrum von tuteinfach bis hin hat 10.000 Stellrädchen. Und ich persönlich bin halt so auf dem Desktop richtig faul und will einfach das tut und hab halt meinen Share und da geht halt dieses Time Machine drauf und speichert einfach. Während auch bei uns auf Arbeit ist das halt ein bisschen komplexer. Da kommt halt wirklich einmal am Tag der Service, nimmt alles auseinander und speichert alles, was sich geändert hat, weg. Aber nicht das, was am Tag davor war und also so einfach Backup. Pro System relativ viele Optionen, wie man es am Ende löst, ist dann glaube ich so eine persönliche Geschmackssache.
Also ich habe im Prinzip das gleiche wie die anderen beiden Jungs hier. Ich habe einen Backup Server zu Hause und mache ZFS Snapshots und Time Machine und alle diese Dinge. Also irgendwann, wenn man genug Ahnung für diesen ganzen Kram hat, dann will man sich doch eine fette Kiste zu Hause irgendwie hinstellen.
Apropos fette Kiste, das würde mich gleich mal interessieren, weil möglicherweise hat sich jetzt jemand das Chaosradio angehört und denkt, es ist so geile Sache, das probiere ich aus. Und fängt das an zu basteln, stellt dann fest, das funktioniert sogar irgendwie. Erzählt dann voller Begeisterung seinen Freunden davon, das ist voll super und es funktioniert. Und ich bin nicht mehr bei Dropbox, sondern bin jetzt sozusagen nur noch mein eigener Admin. Und dann sagen seine Freunde, das ist total geil, dass du das gemacht hast, dass ich mal persönlich das nicht machen möchte, aber kannst du mir nicht einen Account bei dir anlegen? Würdet ihr das empfehlen? Oder sagt ihr eher so, naja...
So fing das bei mir ja an. Ich hab auch irgendwann mal dann angefangen, das dann auch da halb zu, naja, nicht professionalisieren, aber mit einem professionellen Anspruch daherzugehen und dieses Anbieten von Services und dieses Wegseparieren von Diensten, dass sie sich nicht gegenseitig ins Gehege bekommen. Und dann, weil so einen Server im Internet zu mieten, war damals noch so ein richtiges Kostending. Heute kriegt man so einen virtuellen Server für 5 Dollar im Monat. Damals musste es da schon noch mindestens, naja, war es da so mit, da war es noch D-Mark-Preise, ne, da war es so mit 70, 80 D-Mark mindestens dabei. Und dann hab ich dann gesagt, dass ich mir das gerne teilen würde mit Freunden. Und dann haben wir dann angefangen, so allen Accounts zu geben. Und jeder hat sein Mailserver aufgesetzt da drauf und seine eigene E-Mail betrieben. Und jeder hat dann wieder seine Nameserver gemacht. Und dann fingen noch Leute an, Filesharing zu machen. Dann musste man dann irgendwann mal anfangen, das da so zu konsolidieren, dafür zu sorgen, dass nicht jeder in jede andere Software reinfuscht. Und ja, bei der Gelegenheit hab ich ihm gesagt, gut, dann mach ich irgendwie mal einen Mailserver, wo ich den administriere. Und alle anderen können dann ihre Mails damit reinziehen. Und dann fingen das so an. Und dann, wenn du schon mal sowas installiert hast, dann kommt jemand anders daher und sagt, ah, es ist mir grad so viel Ärger und so viele Sicherheitslücken. Kann ich meine Mails nicht auch bei dir? Und dann kommst du dann irgendwann in so... Dann bist du plötzlich so auch Internet-Service Provider. Dann bist du plötzlich auch so... Irgendwann kommen dann auch... Du musst aufpassen, dass nicht da zu viele Benutzer bei dir die Mail-Mittel liegen haben. Und dann musst du plötzlich aufpassen, dass wenn die Leute dann versuchen, ihre Mails rauszuschicken, dann geht's irgendwann nicht, weil jemand behauptet, du würdest von einem Rechner aus Spam verschicken.
Bist du dann auch bei der Bnetz A angemeldet? Da muss man ja auch Mailserver inzwischen anmelden, glaube ich.
Bitte was?
Ich glaube, bei der Bundesnetzagentur muss man heutzutage in Deutschland, wenn man einen Mailserver für Dritte betreibt, den anmelden.
Also auch, wenn ich meinen eigenen kleinen Mailserver betreibe?
Das ist, glaube ich, so Auslegungssache. Ich weiß nicht, ob das kommerziell ist, aber auf jeden Fall, man muss es jetzt anmelden, wie so auch immer. Aber ich sehe halt bei der ganzen Sache, mit Dienste für Freunde betreiben, das macht halt Spaß. Nur man muss halt wissen, worauf man sich einlässt. Also du stellst halt einen Dienst für deine Freunde und Familie oder so bereit. Und die denken dann einfach, du machst das schon, das läuft immer. Und wenn du halt in zwei Jahren keinen Bock hast, musst du ja halt auch damit denken. Du musst halt schon sehen, das betreibe ich halt, ich kümmere mich. Vor allem habe ich dann die Daten von anderen Menschen, um die ich mich da kümmere. Und das ist dann schon eine Verantwortung, die man da hat. Also das ist jetzt nichts, was ich halt irgendwie aus dem Bauch raus entscheiden würde, sondern das muss halt schon, da muss man schon halt ein paar Gedanken machen, bevor man sowas anbietet im größeren Rahmen als für sich selbst.
Naja, größerer Rahmen ist es ja dann, ist es ja erstmal gar nicht. Das ist ja am meisten wahrscheinlich nur so, dass dann der eine sagt, so hier, könnte ich nicht auch mal so einen, keine Ahnung, On-Cloud-Account haben. Da wird es dann auch relativ einfach gemacht.
Weil da gibt es auch... Mit zehn Freunden, die auf einer Party sind, dann ist das irgendwie plötzlich so, ja, dann ist das von jeder Party sind da die Bilder drauf. Und dann plötzlich in einem Jahr so, ja, wieso geht denn das nicht mehr und...
Ja, man muss auch, also wenn man die Geschäftsbedingungen liest, die man da unterschrieben hat, dann ist, muss man auch dazu sagen, dass es meistens sowohl bei den ISPs als auch bei, also manchmal bei, selbst wenn man einen Hoste nimmt, sind da manche Dinge einfach komplett ausgenommen. Aus welchem Grund auch immer.
Inwiefern jetzt?
Na, also zum Beispiel bei den, also Telekom will dich, ein neues Beispiel, eigentlich zwingen, dass wenn du einen Server dritten anbietest, dass du da schon den Telekom Business Vertrag nimmst.
Also wenn ich zu Hause einen Server stehen habe?
Für dich selber ist das noch okay, aber wenn du das für dritte anbietest, dann ist das nicht mehr, hast du, ist, also, steht zumindest nicht in den Geschäftsbedingungen so drin, wie die du da bei deinem Vertrag unterschrieben hast.
Da kommen noch andere Dinge. Die Piratenpartei hatte da so einen Google Docs ähnlichen Service angeboten. Das ist so ein Etherpad heißt es. Und dort haben auch alle Leute drin Texte verfassen können. Und dann hatten sie plötzlich Probleme gehabt, weil wenn du Texte im Internet anbietest, dann stellst du sie zur Verfügung. Du veröffentlichst die und müsstest dann eigentlich in ein Impressum drunter packen und bist dann irgendwie auch, musst einen verantwortlich im Sinne des Presserechts benennen, der dann im Zweifel haftet dafür, dass dort Texte veröffentlicht werden auf deiner Webseite. Dass das allein schon der Betrieb von einem Etherpad-Server kann dir dann irgendwie rechtliche Schwulitäten noch bringen. Da musst du dann schon aufpassen, wie in der Accounts.
Also ich sag mal so, gerade wenn man sich in diesem Anfangsstadium befindet, dann ist es also eher so, nur mit sehr guten Freunden.
Ja im Zweifel irgendwie die mit hochrotem Kopf anzurufen und zu sagen, du, ach ja, übrigens wegen deiner Mail der letzten Jahre...
Also okay, nur mit sehr, sehr guten Freunden. Und denen sagt man auch, aber fürs Backup seid ihr selber zuständig.
Okay.
Gut, vor allem man guckt nicht rein. Also dann sollte...
Machen wir gleich.
Na gut.
Machen wir gleich? Erst mal Nachrichten. Mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Liebe Cottburser, wenn ihr die Sportfreunde Stiller schon immer mal Open Air sehen wolltet, dann reißt doch einfach das Dach von eurer Messehalle ab. Und liebe Berliner, wenn ihr die Sportfreunde Stiller lieber mit dem Dach drüber sehen wollt, dann baut halt eins über die Zitadelle. So oder so.
Fritz präsentiert.
Sportfreunde Stiller. Am Donnerstag den 29. Mai live in der Messe Cottbus. Und am Freitag den 15. August Open Air in der Zitadelle Spandau. Und Cottbus und Berlin. Sportfreunde Stiller. Zwei Mal live präsentiert von Fritz.
Immer gute neue Musik. Fritz Nachrichten.
Union und SPD haben sich auf einen Gesetzentwurf zur doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft für nicht EU-Bürger geeinigt. Kinder, die seit der Geburt neben dem Deutschen auch noch einen anderen Pass besitzen, sollen sich in Zukunft nicht mehr zwischen den beiden Staatsbürgerschaften entscheiden müssen. Voraussetzung ist, dass sie mindestens 8 Jahre lang in Deutschland gelebt haben oder 6 Jahre lang eine deutsche Schule besucht haben. Die Regelung gilt auch für Kinder ausländischer Eltern mit einem deutschen Schul- oder Ausbildungsabschluss. Nach dem Nachrichtendienst Twitter hat die türkische Regierung jetzt auch YouTube blockiert. Das melden staatliche Medien des Landes. Auf YouTube waren zuvor Tonaufnahmen aufgetaucht, auf denen angeblich der türkische Außenminister, der Geheimdienstchef und zwei weitere Spitzenbeamte zu hören waren. Die Männer sollen über eine militärische Intervention in Syrien gesprochen haben. Wie YouTube wurde auch Twitter in der Vergangenheit dazu genutzt, um Korruptionsvorwürfe gegen die Regierung von Ministerpräsident Erdogan zu verbreiten. Die UNO-Vollversammlung hat die Eingliederung der Krim durch Russland verurteilt. Für die Erklärung stimmten in New York 100 Staaten, darunter auch Deutschland. Elf Länder waren dagegen, fast 60 enthielten sich. In dem Text wird die internationale Gemeinschaft aufgerufen, keine Veränderung der ukrainischen Grenzen anzuerkennen. Der internationale Währungsfonds hat der Ukraine heute einen 27 Milliarden Kredit versprochen. Dafür müsste das Land aber strenge Sparmaßnahmen durchsetzen. Für Steuerbetrüger wird es künftig teurer und schwieriger, mit einer Selbstanzeige straffrei davon zu kommen. Die Finanzminister der Länder haben sich darauf geeinigt, die Regeln für die Selbstanzeige weiter zu verschärfen. Unter anderem soll der Zeitraum zur Offenlegung von 5 auf 10 Jahre verlängert werden. Außerdem sollen die Strafzuschläge auf hinterzogene Summen verdoppelt werden. Es sind aber noch Details offen, sie sollen bis Mai geklärt werden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Köpenick 4, Tempelhof 6 Grad, in Prenzlau 2, Falkensee und Wiesenburg und Karlau jeweils 5 Grad. Heute Nacht kann es in Richtung Oder und Neißen noch etwas regnen, der Rest von Brandenburg und Berlin bleibt aber trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken auf bis zu 1 Grad. Morgen gibt es dann wieder mehr Regen, nur etwas Sonne bei maximal 16 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin nach Tiergarten. Hier ist der Tiergartentunnel bis 5 Uhr früh in Richtung Wedding gesperrt. Und zur Berliner S-Bahn. Bis Betriebsschluss ist die Linie S5 zwischen Lichtenberg und Wuletal unterbrochen. Ihr könnt die U5 nutzen. Zudem werden zwischen Bießdorf und Wuletal Busse eingesetzt. Die Linie in S7 und S75 sind zwischen den Bahnhöfen Springfuhl und Lichtenberg unterbrochen. Ein Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen wird eingerichtet. Da, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo heute drei Leute vom Chaos Computer Club zu Gast sind, nämlich der Erdgeist, der Kai und Dmitry. Und die erzählen uns heute, wie man selber Dinge hosten kann. Das heißt, wie man Dienste, die eigentlich, die wir nur aus dem Netz können, wie man die selber betreiben kann. Wir haben schon gelernt, dass, warum man das tun sollte, was man dafür braucht, also was für Hardware man dafür brauchen, dass es sich lohnt, dass, wenn man anfängt, erst mal zu Hause am eigenen DSL zu betreiben. Wir haben gelernt, wie man das so ans Internet anschließt, dass man dann auch tatsächlich darauf zugreifen kann von überall. Und wir haben gelernt, dass es verschiedene Software-Wares gibt, die man benutzen kann, zum Beispiel On Cloud, zum Beispiel ReadyCode, zum Beispiel DevIcle, also verschiedene Sachen, die man auch alles nachlesen kann nach dieser Sendung unter chaosradio.ccc.de. So, und jetzt haben wir gerade noch zum Schluss drüber gesprochen, man hat jetzt so einen Service eingerichtet und man kann jetzt auf seinem ganz eigenen Computer, der im Netz hängt, zum Beispiel Dateien synchronisieren, zum Beispiel seine Kalenderdaten synchronisieren, zum Beispiel seine Kontaktdaten synchronisieren. Und Freunde sagen dann so, er kette das auch gerne oder man hat vielleicht sogar geschafft, einen Mailserver aufzustellen. Man hat jetzt über seinen eigenen Server, der also nicht nur für die eigene Webseite, wie das manche Leute sicher einrichten lassen, sondern wirklich auf der eigenen Maschine, kann man einen Mailserver machen, und dann hat er gesagt, da guckt man aber nicht rein. Das ist ja überhaupt so ein spannendes Ding, wenn ich jetzt so einen eigenen Service betreibe. Als Admin kann ich denn überhaupt immer reingucken oder kann ich das auch gleich so einrichten, dass ich gar keinen Zugriff habe auf das, was die User da machen?
Nee, nur eine Theorie. Also wenn du es selber einrichtest, kannst du im Zweifel auch immer reingucken. Also ich habe auf meinem Mailserver eine ziemlich restriktive Policy, was das Logging betrifft. Das heißt, alle halbe Stunde werden die Logs des Mailservers wieder gelöscht. Wenn irgendwas schief geht, kann ich schnell reingucken, dann sind die noch da. Ich könnte also mit einem Blick sofort sehen, welche Mails da reingehen und welche rausgehen. Und ich kann natürlich auch in die Inhalte reingucken. Ich meine, am Ende ist es nur Software, die auch in einem Betrieb verknüpft wird. Na selbst wenn sie verschlüsselt sind, muss ja damit sie... Also wenn die Mails selber mit PGP verschlüsselt sind, dann kann ich nur in die Metadaten gucken. Also ich sehe, wer wem gemailt hat. Aber kann die Inhalte natürlich nicht angucken. Aber wenn die Mail ganz normal, also nicht ganz normal, wenn die Mail einfach nur von einem Web-Mailer, sagen wir bei Google oder Web.de geschickt worden ist, dann kann ich dort auch natürlich in die Inhalte reingucken. Die liegen dann nämlich einfach im Dateisystem. Zwar verschlüsselt, aber ich hab den Schlüssel.
Als Mailserver-Betreiber sieht man auch mehr Daten als angezeigt werden im Mailclient sozusagen. Man sieht wirklich von welcher IP-Adresse, also vor allem, wenn man die Logs auswertet. Man sieht die IP-Adresse und teilweise die etere IP-Adresse. Also man kann auch wirklich orten, wo der Person wirklich zu dem Zeitpunkt war, als er diese E-Mail abgeschickt hatte.
Deswegen ist bei mir auch so, wenn mir Leute wirklich ganz doll nahe stehen, dann kommen die nicht auf meinen Mailserver, weil ich will mich am Ende auch nicht erklären müssen, dass ich die Möglichkeit hätte, dort in die Mails reinzugucken.
Aber das ist ja quasi dann fast schon so eine Art nicht zu kleines Problem, weil einerseits will man halt nicht irgendwo hingehen zu einem Mailserver, weil da weiß man gar nicht, was passiert, aber man will halt auch nicht zu Freunden gehen, weil es dann, das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an dieses bei Geld hört die Freundschaft auf.
Es ist anders, es ist so ein bisschen wie, warum diese NSA-Affäre erst so wenig Schub bekommen hat, ist es total egal, wenn irgendjemand ein Langley in deine Mails rein guckt oder bei der NSA, kenn ich nicht. Aber wenn der Nachbar in meine Post rein gucken kann, dann hört der Spaß auf, weil das ist dann irgendwie so in meiner Sphäre, die mich dann irgendwie so direkt betrifft. Und das ist, glaub ich, so dieser Effekt, den man dann da merken sollte. Jetzt da bei Web.de oder bei irgendeinem Mail-Hoster, wenn dort die Administratoren in meine E-Mails reingucken, ja hey, ich hab da nichts zu verbergen und die kenn ich nicht, so ist mir egal, dann sollen sie halt reingucken. Das ist dann so eher das Mindset, das einem begegnet, wenn man so mit Leuten spricht, die ihre Mails woanders liegen haben. Als auf meinem E-Mailserver.
Ich überlege gerade, ob es da noch so eine Möglichkeit hat, dass du sagst, du würdest halt Leuten, mit denen du wirklich sehr eng bist, keine E-Mail geben würdest, dann sagen, ich verweise dich aber gerne an hier Freund XY.
Das mach ich auch immer.
Okay, also sagen dann, dass es halt trotzdem noch auf diesem Eigenhosting quasi irgendwie läuft, aber das ist halt nicht die engste Schnittstelle ist. Dann noch eine andere Frage, weil wir haben am Anfang schon drüber geredet, dass man nicht nur zu Hause sich den Rechner hinstellen kann, sondern auch tatsächlich also einfach also Rechenkraft oder richtig Hardware in einem Rechenzentrum mieten kann. Und da ist es ja dann so, also es ist ja, wir haben ja auch schon besprochen, wenn man zu Hause hat dieses beruhigende Gefühl, der Rechner, der ist halt da. So, kann ich halt anfassen und ich kann insbesondere auch mein Zimmer abschließen, dann kann halt niemand da ran. Wenn ich jetzt in einem Rechenzentrum Hardware oder Rechenkraft miete, dann ist das ja schon wieder ein Dritter. Dann ist es zwar nicht Google, aber es ist halt irgendwo, irgendwo eine Firma. Können, haben die denn dann Zugriff auf meinen Rechner oder kann ich einen Rechner tatsächlich so einrichten, dass nur die Leute, die ein Login haben, da Dinge tun können?
Also du kommst, also es gibt halt verschiedenste Methoden. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du in einem Rechenzentrum halt einen richtigen Server, jetzt nicht irgendwie eine virtuelle Kiste gemietest, sondern wirklich einen physikalischen Server, dann kannst du den so rein theoretisch so aufsetzen, dass er zum Beispiel verschlüsselt ist, nur mit deiner Eingabe hochfährt oder so Sachen. Ist aber so ein bisschen grenzwertig, weil tatsächlich könnten die von vorne rein mit lauschen. Und wenn du 100% sicher gehen willst, dann kaufst du dir deine eigene Hardware, baust den selbst zusammen, setzt ihn zu Hause auf und trägst ihn dann selbst ins Rechenzentrum.
Und vor allem, es gab auch genug Fälle, wo zum, also sobald der Rechner hochgefahren ist, dann ist alles in dem Sinne, also vor allem, wenn man von einer verschlüsselten Betriebssysteme oder von verschlüsselter Partition spricht, dann wird alles erstmal entschlüsselt. Also und die, wenn man, wenn man Angst irgendwie hat von der Festnahme seines Servers, dann sind die jeweilige Behörden auch sozusagen schlau genug, um da mit dem Akku hinzugehen, so dass der Server nicht sich ausschaltet, wenn sie das mit sozusagen, mitnehmen einfach.
Aber wenn man, da sag ich halt so weit, wenn man solche Daten, die so gefährlich sind, auf den Servern lagert, dann sollten die erst gar nicht ins Internet, weil die sollten erst gar nicht anfallen zum Beispiel.
Naja, das kann man natürlich leicht sagen, aber andererseits ist es ja so, wir haben jetzt bei diesem ganzen NSA-Skandal gelernt, es wird nichts gemacht, was nicht technisch möglich ist. Wenn man jetzt sagt, setz dich einfach als maßgebend, ich möchte nicht, nehmen wir es einfach so, meine Kontaktdaten oder meine Kalender, die ich synchronisiere, ich möchte nicht, dass da irgendjemand in die Hände fällt.
Dann muss man entweder sagen, man steckt sich das zu Hause an einen Server, den man halt nur anmacht zum Synchronisieren. Oder man geht sogar den Schritt zurück und sagt, naja, dann muss ich halt mein Kabel wieder an den Rechner stecken. Aber wenn man es halt so tatsächlich on the fly immer synchronisiert haben will, dann muss man halt zu dem Punkt gehen, dass halt irgendeine Kiste immer online ist, immer erreichbar und damit auch immer angreifbar so gesehen.
Aber bei E-Mail, E-Mail explizit ist ein interessanter Fall, weil eigentlich gibt es da auch andere Lösungen. Denn wie viele E-Mails brauchst du eigentlich immer synchronisiert haben? Also vielleicht brauchst du die letzte zwei Wochen. Also könntest du theoretisch eine Server Instance irgendwo aufsetzen, wo du die letzte zwei Wochen E-Mail-Verkehr hast. Und ansonsten hast du sie nur lokal auf einem Rechner.
Oder einfach wie früher TM, wo man sie halt wirklich einfach abholt und dann hat man sie auf dem Rechner und fertig.
Genau das, nee, aber das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die man einfach sehr leicht aufsetzen kann. Meiner Meinung nach hat man ein Notebook und zwei mobile Geräte. Und das Notebook löscht halt die E-Mails, die auf dem Server sind, nach zwei Wochen. Und dann hat man gar nicht mehr dieses Problem, dass die jegliche Inhalte auf dem Server sind, sondern man weiß nur, dass zwei Wochen E-Mails auf dem Server sind.
Du merkst, dass wir 2014 haben, wie man sagt, du hast einen Laptop und zwei mobile Geräte.
Ich hab noch einen ganz wichtigen Punkt, der an der Stelle noch gar nicht zur Sprache kam. In dem Moment, wo du deinen eigenen Server irgendwo aufsetzt, hast du natürlich das Problem, dass du mit dem kryptographisch gesichert kommunizieren möchtest. Und allein die Basis, mit dem kryptographisch gesichert zu kommunizieren, ist, wenn du nicht gerade die Kommandozeile benutzt, also wenn du nicht den SSH Zugang darauf benutzt, ziemlich schwierig, weil die Art und Weise, mit denen zum Beispiel über den Browser zu sprechen, ist ja nur dadurch abgesichert, dass in deinem Browser so ein paar Zertifikate, sogenannte RUT-Zertifikate, mit ausgeliefert werden, wo du der chinesischen Regierung, der amerikanischen Regierung, der deutschen T-Systems, irgendwie der türkische Regierung, also sowieso alle mit dabei und alle können, weil sie als vertrauenswürdiges RUT-Zertifikat in deinem Browser eingebaut sind, können theoretisch jetzt, während du deinen Rechner administrierst oder während du einen dieser Dienste dort in Anspruch nimmst und dich dem Gegenüber authentifizierst, können sich in die Mitte hängen und deinen Dienst sozusagen mit übernehmen. Das können sie nicht nur bei dir, sondern jedem, dem du so einen Account mit in die Hand drückst. Und um einen verschlüsselten Dienst anzubieten, musst du dich sowieso erstmal darum kümmern, dass du selber so einen Zertifikat bei einem der Anbieter dir besorgst, um dann auch ernstzunehmend mit Kryptographie sprechen zu können. Da gibt es Dienste, die dir das kostenlos anbieten. Jetzt gab es gerade erst das, dass der Dienst CAs hört, der Zertifikate wirklich in der Community für umsonst rausgegeben hat, weil wenn du dem CA-Root-Zertifikat getraut hast, dann konntest du dir da einfach so ein Zertifikat klicken. Viele Nerdfreunde haben bestimmt auch das CA-Cert mit in ihrem Browser installiert. Es gibt aber auch Firmen, die für einzelne Zertifikate einfach kein Geld nehmen. start.com zum Beispiel ist so ein Dienst, wo man hingehen kann und sagen, gib mir mal einfach so ein Zertifikat, was wirklich nur für die Webseite ist, kann keines Subdomains, aber es stellt dir zumindest Zertifikate aus. Und mit dem sollte man sich auch auf jeden Fall grob beschäftigen, wie dieses SSL oder dieses HTTPS, wie das funktioniert und wie man dann in seinen Webserver solche Zertifikate reinwirft, damit man dann nicht gleich komplett unverschlüsselt mit seinem ins Internet gestellten oder zu Hause hingestellten Computer spricht, wenn man aus dem Internet unterwegs ist.
Ich kann nur empfehlen, falls euch für dieses Thema, also das ist tatsächlich noch mal eine ganz eigene Thematik, die sich spreche mit einem Computer verschlüsselt, Chaosradio 172, SSL oder einmal aufmachen bitte. Da haben wir das mal ausführlich gesprochen, also das kann man sich da noch mal reintun. Das heißt also, ihr sagt aber auch, wenn man sich langfristig mit dem Thema beschäftigt, dann sollte man bunte Software hin und her tatsächlich irgendwann dazu kommen, dass man über dieses SSH-Werkzeug mit dem Server kommuniziert, weil das einfach sozusagen sicherer ist als die SSL-Verschlüsselung.
Ich glaube, in meinen Augen kommt man nicht drumherum, einen Server wirklich irgendwo zu mieten. Also das Beispiel, das wir vor der Sendung besprochen haben, ist eigentlich, man kann gar nicht einen Server, einen Mailserver bei den allermeisten Anbieter zu Hause laufen lassen, weil sie gegen die Zwecke der Spam-Bekämpfung blockieren sie einfach die notwendigen Ports, die man braucht, um einen Mailserver in diesem Netz zu betreiben.
Oder wenn er offen ist und da eine Spam-Erkennungssoftware auf der Gegenseite läuft, die sagt, oh, der kommt von einem DSL-Anschluss, das ist doch bestimmt ein kompromittierter Rechner, ich gebe dem erstmal 10 Punkte und das ist definitiv Spam.
Genau, also man merkt, man schreibt seine Kollegen, die, also ja, man kann eigentlich ziemlich sicher davon ausgehen, man schreibt die, man hat alles aufgesetzt, es scheint alles zu funktionieren, die ganzen Testmails, man kann Testmails hin und her schicken, alles sieht super aus und man schickt eine E-Mail an seinen besten Kumpel, der gerade eine Gmail-Adresse hat und sagt, hast du das bekommen? Und der sucht das 15 Minuten und findet das im Spam. Und man schickt die nächste E-Mail und das landet wieder im Spam und man kommt gar nicht drum herum. Und der Grund ist eigentlich, man hat die falsche Wahl getroffen, wo diese Server eigentlich steht, nämlich in einem nicht vertrauenswürdigen Adressbereich aus Googles Sicht.
Mail ist auch nochmal schwierig, verstehe. Wo wir auch nochmal drüber reden müssten, und zwar, weil wir müssen uns jetzt schon wieder beeilen, wir sind auch gleich wieder vorbei. Aber trotzdem nochmal kurz die Frage, ihr sagt das ja eigentlich in fast jedem Chaosradio, wenn es um Java geht. Java, ein Chatprotokoll, wo es viele Clients für gibt, die relativ einfach zu bedienen sind. Und es gibt halt einen Java Server vom Chaos Computer Club, der sagt halt, also der machst du hier, so könnte das aussehen, die benutzen eigentlich alle. Also wenn du in Deutschland jemanden fragst, wo hast du deine Java Adresse? Und wenn das nicht Google ist, dann ist das meistens der CCC Server. Du sagst immer, ja dezentralisieren, mach doch mal selber so einen Server. Ist das denn auch sowas, was unter diesem Bereich fällt, wo ihr sagt, na hier, Java Server selbst hosten, das ist nicht schwierig, das kann man mal schnell machen?
Ja, also man kann das halt beliebig skalieren, aber umso den einfachsten, so damit man seine eigene Adresse oder seine E-Mail Adresse zum Beispiel als Java Adresse auch benutzen kann. Das ist nicht wirklich schwer, da gibt es halt wirklich How-To's ganz viele, die das wirklich beschreiben und das ist, ich würde mal sagen, eine halbe Stunde Arbeit maximal.
Ohne Vorkenntnisse, eine halbe Stunde Arbeit.
Wenn man es geschafft hat, dass man einen Rechner aufgesetzt hat und so administriert, dass zum Beispiel schon Mailserver läuft, also man sich so grundlegend zum Beispiel eine Linie auskennt, ist das nicht schwierig oder man geht wieder zum Beispiel zu dem Punkt, wo ich glaube Apple Server, also wenn man halt so ein Mac OS X Server installiert hat, kannst du da einfach klick iChat Server anmachen, was auch nur ein Java Server ist am Ende. Und dann macht er das auch. Und ja, das ist halt wirklich nicht schwer, den zu hosten, verbraucht unheimlich wenig Leistung, also und das spricht eigentlich nichts dagegen, wieso man es nicht machen sollte, sobald man Zugriff auf irgendwie einen ordentlichen Server, der irgendwo ein bisschen draußen steht und nicht hinter irgendetwas läuft.
Hatte auch viele Sicherheitslücken, muss man sagen, der klassische Jabberday.
Aha.
Ja, aber das benutzen wir ja auch nicht mehr.
Ausgerechnet, ausgerechnet, Synchronisation und Jabber-Server sind für mich die beiden Anwendungen, die man sehr, also die man eigentlich besonders gut dezentral auf so eine DSL-Leitung zu Hause hosten kann.
Und es ist halt einfach viel cooler, weil man dann nicht irgendwie erdgeist.gmail.org heißt, sondern erdgeist.erdgeist.org. Achso, und zwar der richtige.
Oh, jetzt blicken hier schon wieder die Freunde-Anfragen auf.
Er hätte ja nicht sagen müssen, dass es ziemlich gering ist.
Ich seh's halt bei mir, ich bin halt nicht auf Jabber.ccc.de, sondern auf dem etwas kleineren Berliner Server. Und jedes Mal, wenn Jabber.ccc.de irgendeine Wartung macht, seh ich so, oh, 200 der 100 Kontakte in meinem Jabber sind offline.
200 der 100, krass.
Also, es ist halt einfach eine riesige Menge, die halt dann doch wieder, obwohl es ein riesiges dezentrales Protokoll ist, wie er die gleichen drei, vier Services nutzt, man ist halt so, wieso nicht einfach mehr...
Das ist doch Quatsch, liebe Leute. Ja, so, macht das besser. Jabber.ccc.de aber aussetzen, ist ja also die Hausaufgabe. Was haben wir jetzt noch vergessen?
Files zünden haben wir da irgendwie oder so.
Ich würde noch mal auf so Admin-Ethik zurückkommen, gerade auf diese Freundesache so. So, wenn ich halt für Dinge, für Freunde hoste, dann heißt das so, also ist halt meine Perspektive Ethik, aber ich nehme halt zum Beispiel nicht, weil jemand meinen Mailserver mit nutzt, benutze ich das nie als Druckmittel, auch wenn ich die Person plötzlich abgrundtief hasse. Dann würd ich ihr vielleicht sagen, ja geh mal bitte, ich will dir nicht mehr helfen, aber dann sagen so, nee, ich nehm dir jetzt deine Mails weg und du musst jetzt das tun oder du musst wieder nett zu mir sein und mir ein Kuchen bringen, sonst kriegst du deine Mails nicht wieder.
Du meinst, du würdest nicht beratenbar teilmachen?
So wollte ich das jetzt nicht ausdrücken, aber das ist halt einfach so, du stellst halt einen Service bereit und egal was kommt, du nimmst ihn halt nicht als Druckmittel. Das gehört sich halt einfach nicht.
Muss man sich vorher überlegen, und wie lange man da Energie reinstecken möchte und wenn ich jetzt irgendwann mal sage, ich keine Ahnung, zähne die Karibik aus und dann würde ich auch sagen, so jetzt habt alle noch ein Jahr Zeit irgendwo hin umzuziehen. Ich helfe euch vielleicht noch Vertrauen, solche Services zu finden. Aber so von heute auf morgen aus machen ist einfach ein Unding.
Das sollte man sich dann auf jeden Fall auf die Fahne machen.
Und vor allem wenn der Erdgeist jetzt sagt, ich hab ihm gestern verlinke ich die Mate übers Notebook gekippt und deswegen nimmt er mir jetzt meine Mails weg, bis ich ihm ein neues Notebook gekauft hab. Das ist halt so ein Druckmittel, das ist halt super verlockend manchmal, aber das macht man halt einfach nicht.
Tatsächlich, um den Insider auch noch zu erklären, es war halt neulich, dass die Piratenpartei sich halt stritt. Dann haben halt die Leute, die für die Piraten die interne Infrastruktur machen, also die die ganzen Padserver glaube ich betreiben und die Webserver und die Mails und was auch immer, haben gesagt, wir streiten jetzt, wir machen die Technik aus. Und das ist halt so was, das macht man eigentlich nicht, weil da ging es um einen Partei-Internstreit. Ich hab mich mit einem von den Leuten, die da mit verantwortlich waren, auf Twitter unterhalten und er meinte, er weiß halt aber auch nicht mehr weiter. Also wenn man so einen Service für Freundinnen bietet, dann sollte man sich darüber am klaren sein, auch wenn man charakterfest genug ist, auch im schlimmsten Fall zu sagen, A, ich gucke da nicht rein und B, ich verwende das nicht gegen dich. Also wenn man jemand ist, der eh schon Probleme hat, Smartphones auf dem Tisch liegen zu lassen von Freunden.
Und wenn es dir halt nicht passt, dann sagst du halt, geh bitte oder ich biete dir den Service einfach nicht weiter an. Punkt. Aber halt irgendwie wegnehmen und sagen so, ich erpresse dich jetzt, damit es halt so ganz, ganz schlecht ist.
Also eine Sache, die wo ich gerade so ein bisschen rumspiele, ist ein VPN Server aufzubauen. Also dass ich eigentlich mich über VPN nach Hause einwählen kann und dann eben die Maschinen, die dort stehen und die Services, also die Server, die dort stehen, erreichen kann, ohne dass sie dem Internet sichtbar sind. Und dann bin ich diese ganze Problematik mit, ich kann eigentlich ohne Cloud nicht ganz vertrauen, bin ich los, weil man kann diesen Server nur erreichen, wenn man diese sehr komplizierte Konfiguration, die wenige Schwachstellen hat. Also das wird man nicht einfach ohne... Also man wird einfach diese Hosts, also dieses Server gar nicht erreichen können.
Also um das noch kurz zu erklären, wir haben es vorhin schon mal kurz erklärt, VPN, da ging es um andersrum. Da ging es darum, dass man sagt, naja, man kann das so machen, dass man von außen immer zur selben Adresse geht und dann sozusagen bei sich zu Hause landet. Man kann es auch dazu benutzen, dass man sich von außen, wo auch immer man sich im Internet einloggt, dass man sich erstmal in dieses VPN einloggt und dann ist das quasi so, als wäre man zu Hause im heimischen Netzwerk. So, und diesen Service kann man auch damit machen.
Ich bin die ganze Zeit überlegen, weil tatsächlich bin ich privat weniger Service maintainer und gibt es halt einfach nicht. Weil ich halt einfach sage, ich mache es halt auf Arbeit, Dinge zu administrieren und Netze zu betreiben. Privat will ich halt einfach inzwischen so, ich will da mich nicht mehr drum kümmern müssen. Wenn eine Security-Lücke rauskommt, will ich nicht mehr wissen, Mist, ich sitze jetzt das Wochenende da und muss mein Mailserver updaten. Dann soll ich einfach sagen, also Mailserver und das war's eigentlich, weil ich es privat betreibe, ich würde mir jetzt nicht mehr antun, weil ich einfach das nicht will und halt die Verantwortung gerade keine Lust drauf habe.
Ich bau gerade zu Hause an meinem kleinen Bastel-Atom-Rechner rum und werde dann einen Plex installieren. Das ist eine clicky-bunt, die Oberfläche, die so ein bisschen ist, was man von Apple kennt, wenn man da irgendwie auf diese Menütaste drückt, wo man dann in so einem Karussell sich den Film oder die Serie oder so aussuchen kann, die da auf der Festplatte rumliegt und noch ein bisschen meine ganze verstreute Hardware konsolidieren. Ich hab da ja vorher so einen kleinen Rechnerzoo gehabt mit einem selbst aus Holz zusammengebauten Kasten, in dem die Festplatten da drüben stehen. Jetzt einmal schon alles richtig und mehr Strom sparen, und deutlich weniger Hardware-Tierchen, die da so Dinge tun.
Es ist eigentlich so, dass man, ich habe den Eindruck, wenn man sich das anguckt, diese ganzen Sachen, dass es momentan noch so ist, das gibt dieses On-Cloud und dann noch so ein paar Projekte. Aber dieses hier einklicken und ich installiere das auf einem Rechner, hat das eine Zukunft? Also ist es möglicherweise zeitlich später so, dass wir alle einfach so boxen, kaufen oder nehmen können und dann sagen können, hier stelle ich die zu Hause hin, habe da alle meinst.
Der Tom, der eigentlich heute mit mir sein wollte, aber leider krank ist, der bastelt gerade genau an sowas, wo einfach nur man in so ein Skript eine IP-Adresse eintragen muss und dann spielt er einem sowas wie diese Images, die wir davon besprochen haben, auf und tut das aber selber aus den Softwarepaketen und sorgt dann auch dafür, dass die Festplatte ordentlich verschlüsselt ist und obendrauf der Dienst auch immer aktualisiert wird. Der bastelt auch gerade sowas, dass es für den einfachen Heimanwender zu Hause kurz die Konsole aufmachen, einen Befehl eintippen, IP-Adresse angeben und schwupps hat man den Service installiert. Mit schön dokumentiert, auch für den Anfänger. Also als auch extra für dich, Markus. Als Early Adapter.
Schön, dass du das noch so gesagt hast.
Nee, im Chat kam auch gerade noch das Thema auf, wo lese ich denn überhaupt über Security-Lücken. Und gerade wenn man halt einen Service z.B. ins richtige Internet dann stellt, muss man sich halt natürlich darum kümmern, dass der dann sicher bleibt. Und in der Regel gibt es halt von den Produkten bzw. den Projekten, die halt so eine Software bauen, so Announce-Mailing-Listen oder eine Webseite, wo halt einfach drauf steht, dass eine neue Release rauskommt. Also da sollte man halt definitiv hin dranbleiben, weil das kann halt schon so ein bisschen gefährlich werden, wenn dann irgendwie halt diverse Fotos, die jetzt ein bisschen privater sind vielleicht, irgendwo liegen und du hast eine 3 Jahre alte Software, die sperrangelweit offen ist inzwischen, wo jeder drauf zugreifen kann. Und da muss man schon schauen, dass immer die aktuellste Version dann drauf ist, damit es sicher bleibt.
Das wollte ich auch noch mal sagen. Also was man natürlich auch noch machen kann ist, gerade wenn es um Datei-Synchronisation geht, da hindert dich natürlich niemand dran, wenn du deinen eigenen Service aufgeholt hast, dann noch mal das extra zu verschlüsseln. Also zum Beispiel mit sowas wie TrueCrypto oder Boxcrypto oder was es da alles gibt. Das kann man ja trotzdem auch noch machen.
Genau, aber was ist das halt eigentlich nicht mit einmal installieren getan, sondern das ist halt wie so ein Auto. Dann musst du halt auch mal irgendwie die Reifen wechseln, das Öl nachfüllen.
Es ist halt ein Bastelhobby.
Ja, man muss es halt einfach regelmäßig pflegen, sonst geht es halt ein wie eine Pflanze.
Das ist wirklich demotivierend für mich, denn ich habe einen schwarzen Daumen. Aber vielleicht klappt das ja mit der Software besser als mit den Pflanzen.
Aber wenn es darum geht, zum Beispiel Dateien zu synchronisieren, empfehle ich eigentlich jedem. Also wenn man eine Fritzbox beispielsweise zu Hause hat, dann bietet das sogenannte NAS, also Network Estatched Storage Funktion. Also man kann sich auch von verschiedenen Festplattenhersteller auch solche kleine Boxen kaufen, die eine Festplatte da drin haben, über die man auch irgendwie Dateien sharen kann und so weiter. Und das ist eigentlich der viel einfacher ist, sich das alles selber aufzusetzen.
Aber es macht nicht so viel Spaß.
Nee, das stimmt schon. Also man kann es schon wesentlich mehr machen mit so einer Raspberry Pi, ist ja wirklich ein kleiner Rechner.
Okay, also wenn ihr das gerne mal ausprobieren wollt, dann habt ihr jetzt genug Motivation und genug Anfangspunkte hier im Chaosradio gehört. Es ist mir noch aufgetragen worden, auf eine Veranstaltung hinzuweisen, außer Reichweite, die ein kleines Barcamp, wo es darum geht, dass am 5. April sich mal Leute zusammen setzen und wirklich rausfinden wollen, was man denn machen könnte gegen diese ganze Überwachung, ohne sich in politischen Flügel kämpfen zu verlieren.
Für den am 5.
April statt, außerreichweite.de war die Adresse. Ich würde mich jetzt verabschieden, dass er dennhalb noch einen kurzen Termin zu sagen. Oder noch Werbung für Projekte. Ansonsten kann man jeden am meisten Donnerstag, was sagt ihr mal, Donnerstag abends im Chaosradio ist? Also jetzt gerade kann man in den Chaos Computer Club in der Marienstraße 11 gehen. Mal gucken, was die Leute dort so treiben. Diese Sendung wird uns noch als Podcast geben. Auf fritz.de und möglicherweise auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de Nach uns kommt Hendrik Schröder mit dem Nightflight und wird euch mit Punkmusik bewerfen. Eine Sache war da noch. Erdgeist, Kai und Dmitry, vielen Dank fürs dabei sein.
Und verschlüsselt schön eure Backups. Was der Erdgeist sagt.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.